imagine you had a favorite food like say
wow anchovies
then let's say you had the opportunity
to rock it through a swarm of your
favorite food just opening your mouth
and letting it leap in that's life for
these playful Galapagos penguins in the
waters off the Galapagos Islands the
penguins drive the anchovy swarm into a
shoal of shallow water bunching the
throng even tighter making the pickins
even easier of course every party needs
a pooper in this case the boobers are
pelicans who make like dive bombers to
get in on some of this feasting
the pelicans water-filled pouches are
too heavy to lift and they're too greedy
to let go
and so in a classic case of taking
lemons and making lemonade the Penguins
pick off anchovies from the beaks of
these pelicans sitting ducks in front of
them only when the pelicans back off on
their gluttony and let go of some of
their catch can they surface and enjoy
the bounty and their beaks leaving the
end shall be banquet down below once
more to these gleeful gluttons